Tung tâm phục vụ hàng chính công thành phố Hàn Đội vừa thương báo công thai số địa thoại đường dưới nắng của đần Kim Chá,
giám sát linh ngành hoạt động Kim Só Thủ Tục hàng chính.
Thủ Tục hàng chính nội bộ, Sự Lý Phản Anh,
Kính nghĩ trên nền tảng công dân Tủ Đô số 5.5.
Cũng thế, đông chi của ngọc chàng, giám đốc Trung tâm phục vụ hàng chính công thành phố,
chừng đoàn Kim Chá, giám sát.
Số địa thoại, giá lộ, vay bờ, không bẩy sảo tắm, 2, 2, 2, 1,
thời gian tâm tinh là trong dự hàng chính các ngày làm việc trong đần.
Lỗi dung phản Anh, Kim nghĩ thuộc phản vì tức nền thông tin qua đường dưới nắng
là các hình vi không đúng quy định trong quá trình dạ quyết thủ Tục hàng chính của cán mộ công trước.
Vên trước, người là động của chúng tâm phục vụ hàng chính công thành phố,
các con quan hàng chính nhận nước thuộc thành phố Hàn Đội, về các hình viên sau.
Cơ quyền, xách giáo, gây phyền hà, khó khăn cho Tổ chức,
cà nhân thực hiện Tổ Tổ hàng chính.
Cà nhân lựa trọn hình thức nộ của sơ, nhận chả kết quả dải quyết thủ Tục hàng chính theo quy định của Pháp Lật.
Tổ chối thực hiện, cáo dài thử ra giải quyết thủ Tổ hàng chính hoặc từ ý yêu cầu bộ xung của sơ,
giấy tờ ngoài quy định của Pháp Lật.
Đúng đầy chắc giật, thiếu hợp tác, thiếu công bằng không khách quan, không đúng pháp lật trong quá trình dải quyết thủ Tục hàng chính.
Ón sử, giáo tiếp không phù hợp với quyết trẻ vàn hoa công sử, các hình vi bị phản pháp lật khác trong thực hiện công vụ.